I don't know it's a you don't want to
give anything away and and I should
clarify bit you know I I know I did
tweet something that made a lot of
people think that it was in some way
spoiler and I just I should clarify that
regardless regardless of how Avengers 4
ends I would have tweeted the exact same
thing you know it really was you know
that last day of filming was a very
emotional day and it was the culmination
of almost 10 years of filming and 22
movies this unbelievable tapestry and
you know you you you feel a lot more
emotions than I think even I thought I'd
feel and I felt it was appropriate to
share the gratitude I know it had a
ripple effect but I am neither
confirming or denying anything and to
that end I I think anything I would any
sort of label I would give before--the
Avenger would would give away too much
and a smart man yeah yeah I'm not gonna
cry yes that's wrong with something
really stupid it was something really
dumb which I also probably can't give
away I think it was well it was aligned
I think it was a line too
[Music]
he was overwhelmed with emotion well it
was you know it was reshoot so you doin
these little picks and pops and it's
these little it's it's it's it's it's
just little things that they need it
might have been aligned to Paul Rudd he
wasn't there but it was a stupid line
the line wasn't memorable to me the day
was more memorable than the line I have
a real soft spot for my scenes with
Downey I think you know they they do a
nice job of giving Kap a lot of conflict
in a lot of different ways from a lot of
different places and I personally just
really liked the specific juxtaposition
that cap and Tony pose and over the
course of these movies I think they've
had a really complex dynamic that I
think can be related to on a number of
love it's not just family it's
friendships as brothers it's theirs to
me the most identifiable relationship
for me personally with within the
characters are I mean we didn't I mean I
didn't even get a script for the movie
so I'm looking forward to just knowing
what the hell is going on and how my
scenes fit into the overall context I
think it's gonna be pretty great though
there's so many good things I mean it
really is just an incredible culmination
of this unbelievable tapestry of I mean
how many individual series is it is it
like is it six seven individual plots
coming together it's I don't know that
it's never been done before and I don't
know that I'll ever be done again
and then they really they really you
know stick a flag in the ground on this
one and pull out all the stops and you
won't be disappointed hey everybody it's
Charlie Chris Evans is dropping all
kinds of Avengers for bombs this was at
a recent Comic Con panel if you have no
idea
what was going on they got asked a whole
bunch of questions so I try to just cut
this down to the really important stuff
I'm still doing that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this probably the biggest thing
was him addressing what his very ominous
tweet was all about he says he neither
confirm nor deny what might happen to
him during Avengers 4 what he did say
was as I should clarify that I know I
did tweet something that made a lot of
people think that was in some way a
spoiler I should clarify that regardless
of how Avengers 4 ends I would have
tweeted the exact same thing the last
day of filming was a very emotional day
and it was the culmination of almost 10
years of filming in 22 movies this
unbelievable tapestry I think a lot of
people heard him say that and said ok
he's trying to tell us that he's not
gonna die but he said that he's neither
confirming nor denying anything
whatever you think his ending is going
to be he would have still tweeted that
goodbye to his character I do think that
that backs up the idea that he will not
be returning for any big Captain America
solo films maybe a cameo here or there
but an effective goodbye to the
character for the most part all bets are
off though if they do some crazy Secret
Wars movie in the future where a bunch
of different universes are smashed
together so you get other versions of
Captain America that might still be
around but the other really important
detail that he dropped was is that his
favorite scenes were usually with
Ironman like he says their dynamic and
now obviously you saw during infinity
war they hadn't come together yet
Avengers 4 is all about them putting the
past behind them he kind of tried to
explain that without giving too much
away Kevin Feige has already given a
brief description of what's going on
during Avengers 4 we got a more recent
synopsis about a threat greater than
Thanos I'll link the video that I did
for that at the end of this but even
though his best friend is Bucky and they
have a really strong arc across all
these past movies they've been in but
you can tell because of the way they've
been positioning those two characters as
sort of the leaders of the Avengers
since the first Avengers film why is arc
with Iron Man is just as important as
some of the other big plot things that
are going on so if you're a big fan of
those two characters being together it
sounds like you're gonna get that in
spades during Avengers 4 I do love him
sort of break down a little about how
excited he is to see the movie like
have no idea just trying to tease people
when he says that Marvel's planting a
flag with Avengers for he just saying
that it's so big that no one no other
studio will ever be able to replicate it
in any way either its success or in the
amount of big payoffs that it delivers
that means there are gonna be some deep
cuts all the way from phase one paying
off arcs that they set up way back
during those first couple of films but
the other really funny thing in here too
was Karen Gillan saying that just like
Tom Holland she did not get any scripts
and has absolutely no idea what's
happening in the movie meaning that she
probably shot a lot of green screen to
what they did with Tom Holland on
infinity war especially during the big
Titan set is because it's all motion
capture he would show up in his special
suit and they would just have him fight
say like a bunch of tennis balls and
they would add tano's later in
post-production they never told him what
was going on on Titan what the plot was
it was all one big action scene with a
couple lines of dialogue like the funny
Footloose joke he had with star-lord but
for the most part you don't really need
to give an actor a bunch of pages of a
script if that's all he's going to be
doing in a scene so that's how they get
around not giving away spoilers for
Avengers for the Russos themselves
though just tweeted this out this
picture of the bright blue looking thing
that everybody is still really curious
about this was them finishing reshoots
if you turn the brightness way down it
looks kind of like a briefcase but it
could also just be some of the lights on
set that they use to light the actors in
scenes so don't tie yourself in a knot
too much worrying about this it could be
absolutely nothing because they do love
them some trolling but I've gotten a lot
of requests to do a video for the
supposed description of the Avengers 4
trailer so that'll probably happen
sometime in the next couple of days no
worries congratulations do cheong fun
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here to learn about that
new villain and Avengers 4 and click
here for all my venom Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]